this is Bandhan he's a barber so yes  that is a real animal a member of the  piec family this prehistoric looking  creature is native to the small  Indonesian island of Sulawesi in males  the upper canine teeth grow straight up  through the flesh of its own snout and  curved back towards their eyes as they  get older the tusks can get  spectacularly large and on rare  occasions have grown so big as to pierce  their own skulls  barbarossa spend much of their time  foraging for food eating everything from  roots leaves and fruits to meat and  grubs his strong jaws are easily capable  of cracking the hardest of nuts in its  native island home the Barbarossa has no  natural predators but irva hunting and  conversion of their rainforest habitat  to farmland has reduced their wild  population to less than a few thousand  this is the Barbarossa